on a une nouvelle et chérie c'est le
retour de michel drucker il sera enfin
de retour à l'antenne dimanche prochain
après un an d'absence on rappelle notre
michel a subi une opération à coeur
ouvert un triple pontage après avoir été
diagnostiqué d'une infection bactérienne
c'est bien ça absolument scepticisme et
il a fait un petit duplex avec julian
bugier hier dans le 13h de france 2 lors
de l'enregistrement de l'émission et il
vous allez on enregistre avec lui demain
absolument je suis très heureux il m'a
invité pour mon livre je vais retrouver
michel sur le studio game j'ai commencé
ma carrière de télévision c'est très
émouvant ça très heureux et vous allez y
aller demain pour vos clients
oui absolument c'est de tout le monde
vous invite pour rappel oui c'est même
un jour on vous invitera ça ferait
plaisir
non mais c'est vrai mais je ne dirais
pas vous invite aussi grave on passe par
tous les toutes les étapes
la peur et puis on n'a plus peur et puis
on sait que toute façon ça va mal se
terminer
keira sans doute des séquelles parce
qu'on s'en remet mal comme ça mais
j'étais persuadé que je reviendrai pas
je leur ai dit si vous voulez que je
vous aide à trouver un remplaçant si
vous voulez garder
il m'a dit mme yvonne et il n'en est pas
question stéphane m'a dit qu'on attend
maintenant qu'il faudra quand tu vas
exigeant et je reviendrai au printemps
nous y sommes
michel toujours un sport qu'ils aiment
maurice mon frère d'amour voilà je laime
fort et je suis très très heureux pour
lui qu'ils reviennent ils vaquent
arriver en forme à voir les enfants et
mon michel tu sais que je t'aime voilà
je sais qu'ils nous regardent mais très
décevant michel et on l aime c'est votre
plus beau souvenir de télé michel
drucker basse etc à prix ont baissé avec
lui et c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
commencer à l'époque en direct tous les
soirs et qui pour vous et les trois plus
grands animateurs de de l'histoire dit
michel bien sûr qu'il y ait michelle ye
ses agrumes pour moi il ya drucker est
celui qui m'a qui m'a donné envie envie
vraiment de stuff christophe dechavanne
exacte doit être le show que c'est
c'était vraiment réussi c'est un génie
je pense qu'on est tous un peu des
enfants web ou moins sur les enfants de
christophe et à pau non pour moi c'est
laisser des deux plus marquant est
vraiment moi j'avais de la rue aussi
pour moi y'a qu'a déclaré jean luc
delarue kirk histoire de choc pour moi
c'est les 3 d un c'est vrai c'est vrai
moi c'est vraiment mais ce qui veut dire
s'excuser fou et michel c'est que him a
imagé fait de l'antenne mais j'ai fait
tous les métiers derrière il m'a demandé
de faire du montage de faire des
tournages de cesser moi j'ai appris tout
tous les métiers des prévisions grâce à
lui et honnêtement ces vues d'amérique
au lady voulu retenir drucker
dechavanne non mais c'est vrai ça va
donner mais sans déconner c'est fou
d'ikos d'ikos d'aliaga seul break c'est
un truc de fou web abordé pour cas pour
cartonner en télé dans les jolis seins
patrick des bastien ses clips pour vous
les trois animateurs voix cassée
d'accord en fait c'est moi qui lui ai
souffert donc c'est d'accord avec vous
en fait je préfère guillaume moi je suis
d'accord avec vous je dois ajouter ou
mais ça me touche guillaume bapst futur
proche nous sommes tous et benjamin
était un très grand animateur de prime
que gta v et user des prime en direct et
tulle et toujours mais quand tu faisais
des preuves sur telle mais arrêtez de
dire n'importe quoi ne suis pas d'accord
ça très grands noms
l'animateur de prague et des souliers me
thibout foucault pour moi ils sont fiers
vous faire jean-pierre du cours d'eau
faire locaux c'est vrai mot jean pierre
d'amours aussi c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai voilà dormi voilà moi c'est
de rigueur moindre hoquet m'a toujours
fait rêver
on allait 10,3 formé de 3,3 alors je me
drucker dechavanne effectivement au
début et de la rue parce qu'on ne voit
pas aux débuts pros qu'au début now
début et parce que moi je me souviendrai
toujours je suis arrivé tf1 il était
dans le couloir et j'avais déjà un peu
l'accent bordelais plus que je rêvais de
bordeaux et il m'a dit tu crois réussi
avec ton accent ça m'arrive éduquer avis
une petite vanne sa feria j'ai trouvé
les droits moi j'aurais eu un excellent
roi russie et de la rue et de la rue
était alors dites moi jouer nicolas
pernikoff parce que c'est quand même là
les mecs là on a le grand manitou de la
rue de la rue vous le savez parce qu'on
s'est toujours dit que c'était un génie
d'être long bien sûr si je trouve qu'on
en oublie un d'ailleurs qui vous aimez
beaucoup c'est pierre bellemare j'adore
et pierre bellemare est un orateur
j'étais sur vous ou bien ça c'est un
animateur n'y aura d'ailleurs c'était un
grand animateur d'europe 1 pendant des
années on parle de radio et télévision
et après c'est un homme qui a fait chou
blanc telle est incroyable c'est un
créateur et michel drucker aussi puisque
michel c c'est drôle nagui
la liste des démons pourrait permettre
sophie davant bien sûr remettre une
femme peut-être fait pas ouais ouais ça
non mais si oui c'est vrai dans ma près
après on va pas se mentir alors mélanie
longévité quand même et j'adore j'adore
sophie exceptionnel mais drucker de
shabbat dollars verizon ils ont inventé
des gens c'est ça ouais ça qu'un don
qu'ils ont vraiment marqué de la rue
celle testimoniale dechavanne vraiment
dans le divertissement et et et drucker
il a accompagné les français depuis les
années 50 50 dans sogara par génération
ouais c'est vrai vous par exemple la
génération 2020 et à vous et puis dès
2010 arrive quand même à 2020 vous
n'êtes pas là mais c'est au centre au
bout tu sais ça vous avez inventé un
truc qui avait d'habiliter les veinards
mais vous avez avant si vous avez
inventé un truc qui n'aimait pas
personne a été au-delà autant que vous
dans le fait de dire honnêtement tout le
temps ce qui vous passe par la tête
avant vous personne n'a osé faire ça
mais c'est moi c'est à vous que quand
vous dites à la fin des missions et
maintenant il ya un film tu sais pas
lequel c'est moi ça me choque c'est tout
ce que je veux faire ce soir c'est
incroyable parce que vous êtes vous avez
cassé un code et puis surtout il te dit
il faut répéter que vous êtes sans
prompteur pendant des heures et des
heures en dieu et j'ai appris le sens
vous encore vous sucer un petit peu plus
et je pense que moi j'ai appris un truc
avec vous ses fictions se passer de duke
d'une cadre de la fise d'écouteurs d'une
alarme à un conducteur sas casas modifie
et ça c'est pour le coup c'est tout ce
que je ne connaissais pas du tout ce
qu'est tf1 m6 ça c'est impossible
vous voulez que je vous dise à l'ail et
je ne dis pas ça parce que je je moi je
trouve que les des animateurs à tf1 je
voudrais demander à nicolas pernikoff je
trouve qu'il régresse
parfois ils sont bons sur les autres
chaînes et quand il arrive sur tf1
je les trouve nul mais régresse pourquoi
benjamin pourquoi n'y avait pas clair
des compliqué le voici
mais je casse mais je sais même pas si
mal en ayant fait 5 ans ou 6 ans ou dix
ans avait aussi je pourrais retourner
dans un cadre complètement enfermé je
pense que je serai étouffé je pense
qu'on se je pense qu'il ya une
autocensure sur les rêves jean luc
reichmann c'est l'actrice est alors bon
je vais pas vous sucer mais avait
inventé cette liberté d'expression qui
en fait un retour puisqu'il y avait cet
irt expression via les suceurs non
une liberté à l'époque il y avait comme
des émissions on pouvait un peu tous
dire sur paul à gages sur des missions
sur les premières dechavanne et puis
après ça s'est arrêté
vous avez vu par l'art 15 ans la télé
bien sûr un peu aseptisé et puis à
nouveau vous êtes le seul aujourd'hui
avec peut-être routier qui a cette
liberté de parole et vous encore un peu
plus c'est vrai que vous êtes capable de
jérôme salle ce soir ya un film une le
regarder quand vous laisser en liberté
et en fait vous avez trouvé votre style
puisque vous le savez bien on a essayé
ensemble de travailler sur des formats
sur des concepts machad ça ne marchait
pas je pense que le jour où vous êtes
retrouvé ses jo vous êtes exprimés
librement sur m car il y avait le style
classique d'animation comme un jour
d'ailleurs tout terrain alors qu'en
revanche dechavanne c'est vrai qu'il
avait porté un ton nouveau et un langage
nouveau essayé c'était une très très
grande liberté de ton j'avoue qu'on
était très bleu fait tout ce qu il osé
dire à l'antenne
on